يوم مخصص للاحتفال وفي
مأساة مروعة بعد
مقتل طفلة تبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات عندما انفجرت
طائرة تابعة للقوات الجوية الإيطالية كانت تحلق في تشكيل وتحولت
إلى كرة نارية واصطدمت بالسيارة التي كانت
تستقلها مع عائلتها،
وأصاب الحطام المتطاير سيارة عائلية  كانت تحمل أربعة
أشخاص، قُتلت فتاة تبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات وأصيب
شقيقها البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات بحروق شديدة
ويعالج والداها الآن أيضًا من الحروق، فقدت الطائرة
الارتفاع بعد وقت قصير من إقلاعها،
معلومات الطيران مع الطائرات الأخرى
والقوات الجوية  تكهنات بأنها ربما
اصطدمت بسرب من الطيور،
ويقول المطار إنهم لم يحددوا بشكل حاسم
سبب الحادث، لكن هذه
تكهنات في اللحظة التي
وقع فيها الحادث داخل محيط
المطار مما يعني أن الطائرة سقطت داخل
سياج المطار.  كان المطار والأسرة
يقودان سيارتهما بالفعل على طريق ريفي
في المحيط الخارجي عندما
اصطدم الحطام المشتعل بسيارتهما وانتهى الأمر
بمأساة، وتقول القوات الجوية إنها
ستجري تحقيقًا كاملاً في الأمر